my name is Incheon gal and so topic I
would like to talk about today is random
matrixes and as you know that this is a
new feature that we into are never
introduced in Mathematica a ten-point
10.3 so motivation why do we introduce
many matrices into open language so for
the reasons that we know that's in many
disciplines of research we know they use
matrix model such as in physics that is
this mathematics in the other flying
area like finance and some engineering
fields and when the dimension of these
matrices are large there are some
properties that are independent of the
specific details of the system and like
some of the properties like eigenvalues
will converge to some asymptotic law so
because of this reason in make the study
of when the matrix is particularly
important okay
and actually it can be used to
characterize some of the properties of
the underlying system okay and that's
why this part of the reason that's we
introduced here in the matrices and on
the Espace of workmen language so
previously our sampling framework works
pretty well with the scaler and better
value random variables so we're trying
to go a step forward and try to extend
the same thing framework to open and to
deal with matrix value random variables
and the same time sampling some of those
extended profit lower dimensional
properties of those okay and the
addition to the least mint makes us
value random variables will also
increase the support of some of the
univariate distribution let us derive
from the synthetic properties of the
matrix eigen values and least include
the one sasha has mentioned before one
is the facing wouldn't distribution and
the other ones much uncle posterior
distribution okay
so there are many applications that are
related to random matrices like in
multivariate statistics we know less in
regression where we consider about the
rest of the alternatives low-stress
addresses your terms are essentially
distributed as mentioned Tomoe and if
you consider about a scaled version of
those then those are matrix T
distributed and in other every are like
a PCA manova such in this field the main
focus is on the empirical covariance
matrix and this matrix belongs to
the clasp which is the Wishart
distribution and and one particular
researcher blows this on the eigenvalue
distribution of those and this belongs
to the much honker pasture law and
here's just a PDF of the corresponding
distribution okay and on physics we know
that when the matrix theory introduced
in the story in the study of nuclear
physicists especially on the spectra of
heavy atoms so because most of those
Hamiltonian are quite complicated so
instead of building with laws with first
principle computations some approximates
models while modeling things are used to
approximate the Hamiltonian system like
for example you calcium than symbol and
circular ensembles are introduced to
predict the spectra of the corresponding
system okay
and this framework has also been
standard in using other field of
statistics like a station mechanics
quantum chaos in quantum gas okay and
there are also interesting limiting
distribution associated with looks like
a winner semi circle law which is one
shown that here and the other one is
tracing within law okay and this one is
related to the scaled largest eigenvalue
of the Gaussian ensemble okay
so in the following slides we talk about
the major distribution that we
introduced ok so the first I'm going to
talk about this Gaussian ensemble and as
you know less these are structured
matrixes that consider independent
Gaussian on your entries and as you can
see from here this just probably tensed
here that okay so there are three parter
in poland class which are unitary matrix
district gaussian unitary ensemble
calcium orthogonal ensemble and gaussian
synthetic ensembles so least ensembles
also called in very ensemble because the
distribution of those are invariant
under the Associated transformation like
a unitary orthogonal incent platic and
that's a major previously the motive the
main motivation of introducing these
ensembles
for the study of nuclear physics
especially only on the spectrum of those
okay so as you know that's all these
ensembles well matrix distribution
worked pretty well with our mini
sampling framework like for example in
this case I can simply type a random
barrier here and then specify dr the
distribution like my sample gaussian
synthetic masive distribution is based
by the dimension of it then I can get
our non-kin simple matrix funded matrix
valued random variable for now so in the
following talk about some of the
vacation the application the piece and
the property associated but before I
talk about those I would like to briefly
just talk about the Main Street project
distribution so this is an object that
we introduced to represent the
distribution of the lower dimensional
properties of the matrix property of the
matrix valued random variables so in
order to do so we can just specify
measurable property distribution first
and consider about the expression that
depends on the fence on the matrix value
renderable in the following way and it
could have more than one distribution
and just need to specify learning a list
okay so in the following example I'm
going to use listing which repeatedly on
various applications like the first one
is the well-known we can ER semi-circle
law okay so in order to your loss traces
in Mathematica so currently just need to
use matrix public distribution and
specify the property which is like in
values okay
so the first argument just like in
values of x and with ax distributed that
is for example in this case use Gaussian
orthogonal mixture distribution so I can
simple from that and get eigenvalues
then I can simply combine them together
and see the asymptotic distribution of
them
okay and then come also compares with
the Wigner semi-circle distribution okay
so as you can see with the help of
matrix distribution we can do some some
interesting work adjust so in just a few
lines of code and another important
properties they are associated with the
Gaussian ensemble is lat we can consider
about the spacing of those eigenvalues
and this is you can think of it as the
spacing of the energy spectrum okay and
say for example in this case I can just
simple comes about sampling from the
Gaussian unitary ensemble and then
computer eigenvalues in a case of
dimension two and it's well known that
the the spatial distribution of it is
distributed as the Wigner's - PDF so
just as before we can use mace reply to
properly distribution to do a sampling
from that and compares with rigorous and
wise okay and the last important
properties they are associated with
calcium assemble is that the tracing
with a law and as you know that this one
is associated with the largest
eigenvalue of the matrix okay so in
order to do so again we use the make
sure probably distribution and do some
sampling from that but in this case we
need to do a sort of scaling so they can
converse to they are to have a
distribution like this case so in this
case i consider about the case of
calcium somatic ensemble and this one
belongs to a tracing within law type
beta equal to four
okay
so this is one of the basic movement to
motivate example and the other example
is the circular ensemble so least
ensembles that defined on matrix groups
like a unitary group orthogonal group
and quarter no oh sorry and the
compassion black group okay so the
reason we say like this uniform is
because the probably measure of their
tasting very encountered a group
operation so and it has many different
applications in physics like are because
many athletes property essentially
depends on the symmetries of an unlined
piston on the underlying physical system
and it has one interesting property
which is less for example in the
circular real case it can be used to
generate random rotation matrix in
arbitrary dimension so the computation
of it is quite is pretty straightforward
so in this case just need to use the QR
decomposition to do the sampling of that
yeah the only difficult case is large
typically are Louis QR decomposition
only defined on Rio in contest numbers
but in order to do so we also introduced
only meant some codec and dukey
composition for quaternions other than
the uniform distribution of matrix
groups the super horn samba so consider
about the subset of these matrix groups
say for example the circular orthogonal
matrix distribution is basically the
uniform distribution on symmetric Union
Terry matrices and the other one which
is the uniform distribution on well
synthetic matrices satisfies such
property so again just like the previous
examples we can also consider about
eigen value distribution and spacing
distribution by using matrix property
distribution to do sampling from this
and compared with the limiting law ok so
the first example is about the
distribution again value since we know
that all these matrix are unitary so the
eigenvalues should have a magnitude
equal to 1 so in other catalyze laws we
all need to only
about the face of them so in this case I
sent for the eigenvalues and take the
ark to obtain the phase angle okay and
for the case of circular unitary
ensemble the distribution of phase
should be uniform as you can see from
here okay and the next interesting to
talk about is about the spatial
distribution of least eigenvalues so
basically you can just order in the
eigenvalues bias numerical order
and then compute difference and see how
they distributed and for but lose part
of your case they also converge to their
witness and mice PDF when the
dimensional matrix is large enough from
this example as you can see and there
are also faces application of least
ensembles such as slats are the
distribution of their eigenvalues is the
same as the Boltzmann distribution of
coolant gas in a 2d case while
restricting those gas on the circle so
in this case we can well just write down
to Hamiltonian because you know there's
coolant so the active interaction
potential energy should be taken for a
block as you can see so we can write
down a function which we represented
Hamiltonian and do the sampling from
that's because we know the eigenvalues
up those I mean I mean the face angle
all those distributed essentially as the
circular unitary a circular ensembles
okay
so with this with the sampling framework
that we have we can easily compute it
for example the meaning of the
Hamiltonian to guess on thermodynamic
properties of it then we can easily see
that how the average Hamiltonian depends
on the system size and the horizontal
line just correspond to the theoretical
results when n tends to infinity
and as I mentioned previously one of the
implication of circuit on some boys lats
we can use those to generate rental
rotation so it's just here's just a very
simple example say for example we can
apply the rotation matrix on the vector
and see how they distributed in a space
and this part it should be uniformly
distributed and we can also do this a
step further say for example we can
consider about render rotation in in the
four dimensional case
so again simple a point and then in
order to visualize it we can use a
technique that's called hop maps so we
can map the 3-sphere back to us to
process one so we're going to invest the
the points by using the parameters in s1
to see those so you still hear just the
hop map and then we can just group them
by using the parameters in s1 and
visualize them in animate yep so again
in this case they are just uniformly
distributed because half map preserve
the master during the transformation
while restriction laws ohm dia on the
unit sphere okay and circular ensemble
is also closely related to calculus on
board because you can essentially
construct bound in a motion in circular
ensemble by using the matrix from
Gaussian sampled infinitesimal generator
and here's just one example that this so
in order to do so the first thing we can
do is to sample matrices from couch to
couch in your interior ensemble Segway
so in this case so in this case I simple
100 thousands of blows 2x2 Gaussian
matrices and then I can generate
Brownian paths based on this by using
our initial condition which is a unitary
matrix and simply apply the evolution
operators on them
so in your adidas we can visualize it we
can take a look at the face of those
eigenvalues okay and compare them with
the theoretical result so the previous
two examples I'm talking about are more
likely physically motivated and there
are also other mystery distribution like
for example in this case we should
mention a distribution so the
distribution that is essentially the
distribution of being Pyrrhic or
covariance matrix so in this case is
constructed by taking the two matrices
and my concern about the in this point
so we consider about the list of
multivariate Gaussian vectors so I take
this operation so I can get the
empirical covariance matrix so this
matrix
some boys partly useful in PCA as
mentioned previously and also in
Bayesian inference and also for example
another an important area is that for
example in expectation maximization we
can use the sampling or push our matrix
to construct an issue initial sampling
stage to figure out which one has the
largest which one has a larger
log-likelihood okay so this distribution
is best it can be specified by two
parameters one alone is a degree of
freedom and the other one is the scale
matrix Sigma in this case and another
related ones just inverse which are
matrix but this one is essentially the
inverse of the previous one okay so
which are matrices actually a
generalization of chi-squared
distribution to the matrix case and
interesting property of this that if we
collapse this to the maybe say for
example take projection of this back to
Skater then this expression is actually
chi-squared distributed so again we can
use the random sampling and then
construct your corresponding expression
construct the corresponding expression
and do distribution fix test and also
visualize the results with histogram and
as mentioned previously one particular
important property associated with that
is led the singular values of the future
matrix distributions obeys the motion
compassion law okay so in order to
demonstrate this we can again use matrix
property distribution so in this case we
think of our sample eigenvalues of them
and join them together so we can do
estimated distribution and see which
particular family of it's belong to you
and also again we can also compare the
data with the by using histogram and the
online PDF and also another thing to
talk about this ladder so so a Tracy
whedon law associated with Wishart
ensemble Bakula this one okay the other
two I'm going to talk about our matrix
normal and matrix T distributions so
these are just are also the
generalization of normal integers
distributions to the matrix case so in
matrix normal distributions there are
two parameters to specify one is the
Rope for variance and the otherwise the
covariance on the columns and also you
can specify you to have a nonzero mean
there as a matrix there mm-hmm and make
sure this T distribution while the
definition of a dispersion much similar
as the in the univariate case or the
better case because this is just the mr.
distribute prompter mr. distribution of
matrix normal with Sigma sample from the
inverse Wishart okay okay and here just
some of the examples like so example all
these mr. dissociation works well works
pretty well with our window sampling
frame works so we can simple from this
and do some visualization
say poison of all this one so you can
give you some qualitative idea about how
the
data is called correlated and also
matrix normal distribution can also be
using unconditional sampling of some
discrete time series process like this
one if the covariance matrix are given
explicitly say for example in this case
we can use matrix normal distribution to
sample from scalar autoregressive
process driven by a multi various noises
no so in this case I just need to
specify the role covariance and column
covariance then do the random sampling
to gather data and also we can compare
it with the our process by using our
function of estimated process so the
previous examples I talked about are
mostly related to matrix valued random
variables and there are also important
things like they're like asymptotic to
limiting law say for example in this
case there are two important limiting
law that I have briefly talked about
previously which are one of them is
mechanical password distribution and the
other one is the tracing within
distribution so much uncle password
distribution is just the asymptotic to
distribution of singer values of
matrices from Fisher and ensemble so it
can be characterized by two parameters
so one of them is a scale shape
parameter and the other one Sigma is it
a scale parameter okay so the behavior
appears really depends on the parameter
lambda here so for example when lambda
is less than 1 it has a well-defined PDF
okay as you can see but when because
London becomes greater than 1 then the
distribution is going to build up a non
nonzero atomic weight at 0 and the
reason of this is pretty straightforward
because that when we construct the which
are matrix like this
when the lambda is greater than one then
the number of columns is going to
greater than number of rows so in last
case it means less is going to have a
the dimension of the null space is going
to be nonzero
so in that case that's the reason it's
going to build up and atomic waste here
at zero okay I guess the most important
example is probably about a tracer
wouldn't distribution so as you know
that well is the distribution of the
scale the largest eigenvalue from matrix
ensembles like a Gaussian ensemble which
are known some bowls so in order to do
the computation well actually they are
the the CDF of this distribution can be
expressed in closed form but however
well there are two equilibrium
equilibrium expression of this one of
them can be expressed in a solution on
pen level typed equation of the solution
and the very question type to you
however if you want to numerically solve
this equation it's quite difficult
because that the equation itself is
nonlinear still so in order to stop them
properly and especially in this case you
need to solve is in the domain which is
from zone bounded no finite number to
infinity and this make it very difficult
to do so so instead of using this
formulation we actually adopt a
different one which is by using another
representation which is by using the
fedone determinant so in that case you
need to evaluate the don't Terminal two
murkily by properly truncating that and
with the kernel function there to form
the PI root function okay but actually
doesn't really solve the whole issue
because for example in the either the
left arrow right tail if you use the
formulation of blood on deterministic
valuation murkily you will typically get
into some issue like a numerical
cancellation or either in the opposite
case we are going to encounters highly
oscillatory behavior of ayran functions
so in legs in that case in major
convergence real slow unless you specify
a large amount of point so
so in the when the magnitude of the X is
large we simply used asymptotic behavior
asymptotic expansion of it but one
important case last when the for example
the variable the the value of x is small
say for example though the 10 by
negative in that case we're also going
to encounter staying issue because we're
going creating get into the oscillatory
Jing a viral function so in last case we
actually use a mixed strategy so half of
them we computer them by using the
freedom determinant and the other parts
we use the asymptotic expansion of in
the middle to the solution of pivot to
equation okay and this works pretty well
in your test okay so for this resolution
the PDF and CDF is supported and those
so the moment I was all supported but
instead of just Latin evaluates into
machine position you want you if you
want to see the numerical approximation
of this you need to apply the function
notice to see the result okay and we
have also pre computed the meaning of
tracing with the distribution up to 50
digits of precision okay and the next
example is to show the tale of first
witness CDF so and here are just the
approximation of the fist a witness idea
in in log scale okay so we can see them
and visualize on the plot so on this
scale is probably couldn't see any
different but if we consider about the
relative arrow between them so just
simply divide one by another then you
can easily see last asymptotic expansion
don't perform quite well it's going to
happen arrow as order of 10 to the minus
three so that's the reason we adopt the
strategy that I mentioned previously on
handling the computation of Li CDF
so due to the reason that I mentioned
previously the computation of tracer
wouldn't distribution can be quite
costly if we didn't do any per
complication to get some parts of the
results in the in the central regime so
but there's actually another strategy on
dealing with this which is that I just
common knowledge in statistics that we
can approximate face it with the
distribution by using gamma distribution
and here I can show an example that
there's say for example we consider
about the government distribution with
three parameters and here's the four
corresponding point with PDF okay so in
order to match gamma distribution with
face it Whidden the thing we can do is
to come is to match the leading the
first of the three leading moments okay
so we can specify the moments of gamma
distribution and also numerically
evaluate the moments of tracing within
the distribution like a mean variance
the skewness and then I can do a find
rules to find out all those parameters
okay and then I can compare the PDF
between them in the range which is
greater than Phi minus Phi by less than
Q okay at least goes probably couldn't
see any difference but if we go a little
bit closer to the tail then you can you
see that they have several order they
have a difference of server order of
magnitude okay so it really depends on
your preference that what sister what's
the region that's your interesting okay
and the last example is that the one
such as mentioned previously or so I
just skip this one so yeah I think sense
my talking here is just a final remark
so in Mechelen point three we introduce
several different thing like our so the
most important points about the sampling
of matrix value random variables like
the one belongs to a Gaussian ensemble
circular ensembles and some other
important makes to diffusion like a
Wishart matrix normal and measures T and
also we introduce new objects that can
be
to represent the the lower dimensional
properties of matrix value random
variables and also layer two univariate
distribution they are related to the
limiting distribution back in values
okay thank you for your attention